-We now have the audio
of a damning phone call
in which Donald Trump's
former lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
explicitly dangled
a quid pro quo
to pressure Ukrainian officials
to interfere in
the 2020 election
to help Trump
and hurt Joe Biden.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As we all know,
Rudy is currently under
what we can only assume
is a very serious
criminal investigation,
given that they raided
his home and office
and seized his
electronic devices.
This investigation could
very well land Rudy in jail.
According to another
former Trump associate
who's already been there.
-Investigating Donald Trump,
as prosecutors ramp up
their investigation
into the former president.
Another name always comes up,
doesn't it?
Rudy Giuliani.
Could the former mayor
end up in prison?
-The FBI is not raiding his home
without having extremely
significant documentation,
information within which
to pursue this.
There's no way in the world
that they're going to
let him off the hook.
What Rudy needs to do
is like what I did --
you need to take responsibility
for what you did wrong.
What Rudy needs to do --
and this is my speech to Rudy
and to anybody else --
they have him,
and so if he's looking
to protect himself
so that he doesn't end up
spending the rest
of his life in prison,
he may want to actually
start to cooperate.
-Somehow,
Michael Cohen has become
the wise, elder statesman
of former Trump goons.
He used to be the intimidating
Mafia-style bag man,
and now he's like
a guidance counselor
sitting backwards on a chair
to give Rudy a pep talk.
"You've got to straighten
out your life, man.
You could be somebody,
but if you keep hanging out
with the wrong crowd,
you're going to find yourself
working down at the gas station
for the rest of your life."
"But I love the gas station.
That's where I get my hair dye."
It's fitting that Cohen
looks like
a bargain bin Ray Romano now,
because he sounds like
he's giving brotherly advice
to Robert.
[ As Ray Romano ] "Oh, Robert,
you got to take responsibility
for what you do.
You got to tell Ma
you broke her vase."
"Raymond, don't tell mom
about the vase, Raymond."
And we have heard the feedback
and understand those impressions
are polarizing,
so do please go to
@seacaptainpolls on Twitter,
where you can either vote
"Everybody loves Seth's Raymond"
or "Everybody hates fun."
So if you take Cohen's
word for it,
Rudy could very well
end up in jail.
And I know we've been saying
some version of that sentence
about a bunch of different Trump
cronies for over four years,
and yet somehow it feels like
they all evade accountability.
I mean, Steve Bannon's out there
just doing a podcast
like a 22-year-old stand-up,
and looking like
he's about to film a scene
in the new "Aquaman"
where he plays, I don't know,
a guy who guards the sea cave,
despite the fact
that he got arrested
by the Postal Service
police force
on a Chinese
billionaire's yacht,
an insane thing
that actually happened,
and not, as I first thought,
a lyric from the Don Henley
song "Boys of Summer."
I mean, he got arrested
by postal cops
at a Chinese
billionaire's yacht.
♪ Don't look back,
you can never look back ♪
That probably won't even make it
into the history books
about the Trump era, because
there's just too much to cover.
And it's such a bummer,
because there should be
an entire chapter
devoted to the fact
that the Postal Service
has a police force.
Personally, if I were
in high school,
I'd be psyched to learn there
are Postal Service cops.
If I found out about that
in 10th grade history class.
there's a good chance
I'd be out there right now,
walking the beat
in those short shorts
with my bucket hat
and a badge,
solving mail crimes with
my unorthodox method,
and Chief would always
be trying to muzzle me, saying,
"Meyers, I got the mayor
breathing down my neck
thanks to your stunt."
And I'd say,
"What am I supposed to do,
just cram the whole Pottery Barn
catalog through that tiny slot?
I had to break those windows."
And he'd say,
"You're gonna fly right,
or I'll have your badge."
And I'd say to him,
"Sorry, Chief,
but I'm like an envelope
with photos inside.
I do not bend."
You know, I should probably stop
before I give away
the entire plot
for my new collaboration
with Dick Wolf,
"Chicago Postal Service
Police Force."
[ One chord of "Law & Order"
theme plays ]
The cheapskates at NBC would
only pay for one of the "dun"s.
"Chicago Postal Service
Police Force"
is just one of the many ways,
along with my new company,
MyZipper,
and my Broadway musicals,
"Cicada, Cicada,"
that I'm soon going to be the
richest man in the world.
Anyway,
what was I talking about?
Oh, right. Rudy Giuliani.
[ Chuckling ]
So, who knows?
Maybe Cohen's wrong,
and Rudy will end up fine
like the others,
but I just can't imagine
the feds
raiding Rudy Giuliani's
home and office
and finding nothing
incriminating.
I mean, forget Ukraine
and quid pro quos.
He's probably got
a fridge full of
whitefish he stole from Zabar's
or a sink full of
unpaid parking tickets
he tried to stuff into
the garbage disposal,
only to remember
he doesn't have one.
He's probably breaking all kinds
of co-op board rules, too,
especially with that
welcome mat.
And you know
he probably has neighbors
that are happy to rat on him --
maybe a guy who,
and I'm just spitballing here,
is in a bathrobe and a Yankees
head who's eating a bagel.
"Hey, you guys looking
in Rudy's apartment?
Yeah, okay, because last week
he woke me up at 3:00 a.m.
He asked me to hold this Bitcoin
for him in case the cops came.
It was just a duffel bag
of old subway tokens.
Also, do you know
he married his cousin?"
One sign that
the investigation is serious
is that federal agents
seized his electronic devices,
and apparently he had
a lot of them.
According to a court
filing last month,
prosecutors seized
18 electronic devices,
including phones and computers
belonging to Giuliani,
as well as certain
employees of his firm.
Alright, first of all,
what 77-year-old man
has that many
electronic devices?
"Yeah, Chief,
we found three phones,
two iPads,
a Palm Pilot, an Atari 2600,
three blood pressure cuffs --"
"Meyers, I thought I told you
you were off this case."
"The Postal Service Police Force
are never off the case!"
[ One chord of "Law & Order"
theme plays ]
Was that the same "dun,"
or the back "dun?"
So I can only get
each one one time?
Also, I'm sorry,
Rudy Giuliani has employees?
Can you imagine working
for this guy?
"Hey, honey, I'm going
to be home late tonight.
Yeah, the boss thought
he had reservations at Morton's,
but it just turns out
he bought some salt.
I'm laughing, too."
I can't picture Rudy actually
being in charge of people.
When I imagine him
employing someone,
I just assume he pulls aside
a kid on the street
and flips them a nickel
to run an errand for him
like he's Chazz Palminteri
in "A Bronx Tale."
"Hey, kid, take this briefcase
full of cash down to the docks.
You come back alive, I might
have something bigger for you."
And now we may be getting
a better idea
of what exactly federal agents
might have found
on all those devices.
Let's first take a trip
down memory lane,
back to the first impeachment
of Donald Trump.
You might remember
the central allegation
that during
an official phone call
with the president of Ukraine,
Trump had tried
to extort Ukraine
and get them to interfere
in the 2020 election
by digging up dirt on Biden.
We all read the transcript,
where it was very clear
that what Trump was doing
was dangling a quid pro quo.
And yet Trump denied it,
uttering the same refrain
so many times,
it almost started to sound like
a religious mantra
you would hear on the street
from some weird cult member
trying to convert you.
-There was no quid pro quo.
There was nothing.
There was no
quid pro quo at all.
If you remember at the
beginning, it was quid pro quo.
But listen to this --
there is no pro quo.
-That sounds like
something you'd say
when you get stopped
on your way to work
by some German tourists
in Times Square.
"Excuse me, can you tell us
where to find the M&M store?"
"Uh, scusi. No pro quo."
Ah, the good old days, huh?
So quaint, back when the biggest
scandal in politics
was the president trying
to extort a foreign country,
before we were all trapped
in our homes for a year
to avoid a deadly plague
and a violent mob
tried to overthrow democracy.
♪ Don't look back,
you can never look back ♪
Look, I'm sorry
all my references lately
are for 50-year-old men,
but look at my audience
right now.
I mean, I bring
in younger people,
but their little hands
can't hold all the cue cards.
Now obviously, you don't
have to be a lawyer
to guess that a quid pro quo
sounds super illegal,
so that was their line --
there was no quid pro quo.
But now we have damning
new audiotapes of a phone call
Rudy Giuliani had with
a Ukrainian official in 2019
in which it definitely sounds
like there was a quid pro quo.
-CNN today obtained audio of
a 2019 phone conversation
between Rudy Giuliani
and an adviser
to the president of Ukraine.
In that conversation,
which again, took place in 2019,
Mr. Giuliani can be heard
pressuring
the Ukrainian government
that their president
must publicly announce
a sham investigation into some
alleged wrongdoing by Joe Biden.
-The audio obtained
exclusively by CNN
is from a roughly 40-minute call
between Giuliani, a US diplomat,
and a Ukrainian official.
-Alright, first of all,
how is it that
every time these guys do
something shady or illegal,
they get caught on tape?
At this point,
they're less like politicians
and more like Twitch streamers.
"Hey, guys, Brad here,
about to bribe a foreign country
to interfere in our elections.
Figured I'd go live.
Also I'm gonna try
another speedrun
on 'Super Mario Brothers.'
I keep getting eaten
by the chain chomp,
which totally blows."
We on purpose didn't
give Wally lines today,
because when we do,
we have to pay him extra money,
and I'm trying to save
as much money as possible
so that NBC will let me
buy an M.C. Hammer sample,
and I'm getting
as creative as I can.
Like the other day,
I brought our budget
to our line producer, Jen,
and I said,
"Hey, right here there's
all this money for suits,
and I'm not wearing
suits anymore.
So couldn't we use that money
to pay for M.C. Hammer?"
And she just looked at it,
and you know
what she said to me?
"You can't touch this."
[ No music playing ]
Also, my sympathies
to the Ukrainian official.
This call was 40 minutes long.
40 minutes.
If I'm on the phone
for more than three minutes,
it ruins my entire day.
The only time I've ever
on the phone that long
is if I'm fighting with
the automated customer service
agent at Verizon.
I just want to
cancel my service!
-I heard you want to
upgrade your service.
Is that right?
-No, I said cancel my service.
-I heard you want to add stars
for $15 a month.
Is that right?
-No, I want to cancel.
-I heard you want to purchase
"Wedding Crashers 2" on demand.
Is that right?
-Yes, I do.
Can we just take
a moment to acknowledge
that the rumors
of a "Wedding Crashers" sequel
are finally gaining steam,
mere months after
we started referencing
the original on this show
for literally no reason?
Well, not no reason.
The reason is there's
no audience here
to say, "Jesus enough."
Still, you're welcome.
I don't know much about
how the sequel got started,
but I bet the conversation was
a little something like this --
[ As Vince Vaughn ]
"Buddy, buddy, buddy.
We got to shoot this sequel.
People have waited long enough.
They want to know
if we're still crashing."
[ As Owen Wilson ]
"I'm not sure, man.
I feel like we'd be messing
with the integrity
of the original."
Anyway, where was I?
Oh, right. Rudy.
The fact that the phone call
is 40 minutes long
means there's lots of
damning stuff in there.
For example,
Rudy had this insane theory
that it was actually Ukraine
that interfered in
the 2016 election to hurt Trump,
and he wanted
Ukrainian officials
to investigate that theory.
-Way back in last November,
I got information from
a reliable investigator,
international investigator,
that there was a certain amount
of activity in Ukraine
during the 2016 election
that was, that involved
Ukrainian officials
and Ukrainian --
mostly officials
being asked by our embassy
possibly by other
American officials.
Basically, I mean, the statement
was to produce dirt
on then-candidate Trump
and Paul Manafort.
-I have a feeling I know who
this international
investigator was.
[ As Mike Lindell ]
"That -- that would be me.
I'm the one who told Rudy
Ukraine interfered
in the election to hurt Trump.
I heard it from Sidney Powell
and Hugo Chavez
in a secret meeting that was
recorded by Italian satellites.
But also, you got to remember,
I'm real tired all the time
because my pillow sucks.
plus I sleep in the woods,
and I got really nervous
because of all the bears."
So that's -- let's see, that's
Lindell, Vaughn, Wilson, Romano.
Did the Smithsonian
ask for anything else,
or can we just send this over?
I'd sell an NFT
of this "Closer Look,"
but I already got
too much money.
But then Rudy got down
to business
and made it clear
that what he and Trump wanted
was for Ukraine's president
to make a public statement
declaring that they were opening
an investigation into Joe Biden.
-What we need, all we need
from the president is
to say, "I'm gonna put an
honest prosecutor in charge.
He's going to investigate
and dig up the evidence
that presently exists,
and is there any other evidence
about involvement
of the 2016 election."
And then the Biden thing
has to be run out.
I don't know
if it's true or not.
-No, you don't.
These guys can't even
bring themselves
to believe their own B.S.
This is how they always do it.
They float insane theories
and then cover themselves
by saying they're
just asking questions,
like they're gossipy
high school sophomores.
"You need to break up
with Todd ASAP,
because I heard he went to
Jenny's lake house last weekend
and told Brad
that Karen told Michael,
who told Emma's teammate's
cousin's brother's mom
that she has a crush on him.
I don't know if it's true."
And it was clear
what they were doing was shady
and that they knew
it was shady,
because they all talk in
that vague, Mafia-esque tone
where they never actually
demand something explicitly,
but they make it very clear
that what they're asking for
is a quid pro quo.
-If he could make some
statement at the right time
that he supports a fair,
honest law enforcement system
and that these investigations
go wherever they have to go,
it's gonna be
run by honest people,
that would probably
clear the air really well.
And I think it would
make it possible for me to come,
and make it possible, I think,
for me to talk to the President
and see what I can do about
making sure
that whatever misunderstandings
are put aside.
And maybe even, I kind of think
that this could be a good thing
for having
a much better relationship,
where we really
understand each other.
If he could say
something like that on his own,
in conversation,
it would go a long way
with the President
to solve the problems.
-"It would go a long way
to solve the problems."
Rudy sounds like he should
be wearing a track suit
and running his fingertip
along the bar
at a New Jersey restaurant
saying,
"This is a nice place --
nice and flammable,
if you know what I mean."
Also, I love that Rudy's reward
for their cooperation
was saying that he
would personally
visit them in Ukraine.
I'm sure they were psyched
about the idea of Rudy
showing up at their door,
asking to sleep on their futon,
and then spending three days
talking about cigars
and the Yankees
and asking them where to find
the best salami in Kiev.
"I'm jonesing for some Genoa.
Mind if I put my cigar
out on your rug?"
This whole thing is
yet another reminder
of the central thrust of
Republican politics right now --
cheating in elections to win.
They made it clear they'll do it
any way they can,
whether it's using
the levers of the state
to pressure government officials
to overturn elections,
passing voter suppression laws,
or extorting foreign countries.
They didn't stop
after the Ukraine scandal,
and they're not stopping now.
It turns out the biggest
criminals are the ones
in the so-called party
of law and order.
[ Two chords of "Law & Order"
theme plays ]
Oh, the gave them both.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's love, We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, wear a mask,
get vaccinated.
We love you.